[Music]
jason reid works for espn's be
undefeated and we thought we'd bring in
Jace because he covers the Washington
Redskins he's at the airport now get
ready to head to the combine and this
whole Kirk Cousins situation is
fascinating right now Jason and I don't
know if it comes to fruition with some
kind of answer here at the combine what
do you think happens here with her
cousins well then I think tomorrow
they'll apply the franchise tag and once
they do that I think it's we're headed
down a road where he's not going to be
the quarterback here long term and we've
been coming to this point for some time
now you know cousins then has always
wanted to be somewhere where he's wanted
and he's one of the people at the
highest levels of that organization to
truly want him and when the time he was
a rookie he's never felt truly
appreciated here and part of it was
because he was never supposed to be the
guy they spent all the pics on Robert
Griffin the third and Robert Griffin if
there was going to be the guy when will
that didn't work out they had no really
other alternatives so they went with him
and he's proven he's a capable
quarterback whatever anybody thinks of
is he a star is your top ten he is a
capable quarterback in the National
Football League but I don't think he's
going to be here long term because of
the way the situation was played out now
if you're Kirk Cousins do you say I
applied the franchise tag and then do
you somehow end up in San Francisco
reunited with Kyle Shanahan or if you're
Washington is there way that you
facilitate a trade there and get a high
draft pick in return well the the
problem dan for the Redskins is if they
really have no leverage here cousins
country cousins has all the leverage he
it's pretty much known in the industry
that he wants to reunite with kyle
shanahan the guy who stood on the table
but said okay I want to use a
fourth-round pick on him even after all
the pics they used to get Griffin he
wants to be back with my shanty and
that's known throughout the industry
Kyle shannon has a six-year deal Kyle
Shanahan can wait it out this year if
the Redskins want to keep cousins or if
they ask for some ridiculous amount
matrade demand and you can just like no
we'll wait it out and you're not going
to tag them next year when you'd have to
pay them 35 million dollar
so outside of next year and i'll deal
with all the other issues that I have
with this roster with the San Francisco
49ers so a trade would be the best
scenario for the [ __ ] but they don't
have any leverage here jason is a senior
NFL writer for ESPN's the undefeated a
full introduction for him and with that
in mind of the quarterbacks though that
could be like Garoppolo I don't know if
cousins affects the draft Tony Romo if
he affects the draft any any other
quarterbacks here that you see that
could shake up the first round well the
two guys you just mentioned obviously
could in terms of whether or not you
know there's an impact throughout the
draft with any other guys moving I mean
those two names those are the ones that
everybody's talking about as far as romo
goes you're looking at a situation a
landing spot for him we're a team has to
be in a really good position not just in
a good position for the talent
standpoint but a good position with
management structure you don't know how
much Tony Romo has left me he's gonna
probably would forget problems you don't
want to go someplace where he's got a
shot to win so I think when you're
talking about the draft those are the
two guys and though those are the ones
that everyone's looking at right now but
could you could you see real meal plan
for Washington again I I can't fathom
that I had I also don't think it's a
good fit for him I don't think it's
somewhere where he would really want to
be I mean you look at the steamed in
their defense is a mess they could lose
both of their very good veteran wide
receivers there are questions about
what's going on with their management
structure so I don't see that being a
place he wouldn't you want to go and
giving his relationship with Jerry Jones
I don't think Jerry Jones would stick
him somewhere where he doesn't want to
be and also looking from jerry jones i
did you really don't want him and no no
that's not that's not what you got an
ideal situation so I I don't see that
happening if I gave you over/under
number of quarterbacks taken in the
first round at three and a half you're
going over or under I i I'd go over just
because they're going to I think there's
many teams like the Washington Redskins
who are still so unsettled at that
that you're going to take a shot now
when you look at wait there your name is
your first round pick on a quarterback
let's say at this point at this point I
don't think you can rule anything out
I'm not saying they definitely would do
that but depending on how this cousin
situation plays out it is somebody they
like up high based on their evaluation I
don't think I don't think they can I
don't think they will do anything out
and I don't think they can how about the
number of quarterbacks in the top ten if
I put it at one and a half quarterbacks
taken in the top ten I i I'd be more
likely to agree with you on that but but
when we're talking overall draft I think
you know and then you know this as well
as anybody at this point heading into
the combine everything is on the table
once we start getting closer to those
days where you actually have to make the
decision then things start to change the
right now I mean you could you could
thought any number and you know going
into the first week of March and I would
have to say well maybe jay says save
travels to the combine have fun with
your stopwatch oil through man thanks a
lot 9 that's Jason ring senior NFL
writer for ESPN's be undefeated the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience
[Music]